nous
apparence catégoriquement inacceptable directement
à nos frontières
Alliance de l'Atlantique Nord
surtout compte tenu de tel ou tel cours
qui détient le leadership ukrainien
à la fois ancien et actuel malheureusement
en outre
cette ligne rouge est pour de vrai ils le sont
connaître le deuxième moment même si
l'ukraine reste dehors pour ça
des accords bilatéraux sont possibles
avec les américains avec les britanniques avec d'autres
Les pays occidentaux qui y créent
installations militaires
les bases sur la mer d'Azov ne sont pas pour nous non plus
acceptable car hébergement sur
territoire
nos voisins dans ce cas l'Ukraine
frapper des armes qui
constituer une menace pour la Russie
la fédération est une autre ligne rouge